c'est une discipline presque
confidentielle dans le monde du
parapente est certainement la plus
spectaculaire la voltige ils sont une
poignée à la pratique et à la réunion
tout ce sont bien sûr des pilotes
chevronnés et certaines enseignes même
cette discipline dans leur club
sensation sport les a attrapés au vol
rencontre avec manu yann et alain
voltigeurs que vous avez peut-être déjà
vu évoluer en plein ciel de saint leu
lors des derniers championnats de france
de parapente notamment
dans le parapente et plusieurs
disciplines moi donc il existe aussi la
voltige qui peut se dérouler en
compétition là on va chercher plus des
sensation d'adrénaline plus forte on va
chercher les sensations de glisse du
pilotage un peu plus l'otage plus
extrême est plus fin suivant les figures
pierre klein de figure possibles et des
enchaînements différents qui sont
possibles avec le parapente et en
fonction du niveau du pilote et à une
progression un peu cheap qui existe on
va commencer un peu plus par des wings
over débalancé droite gauche on arrive
petit à petit remonté carrément au sud à
voile
un pilotage actifs de jouer avec le vent
c'est vraiment on va suivre c'est
vraiment la glisse au maximum et pour
pas mal de figure on va chercher à faire
des grosses prises de vitesse pour avoir
beaucoup d'énergie
le parapente à la base ça fait partie un
peu des sports à risque ou en fonction
de son niveau des conditions dans
lesquelles on fait mais on arrive à
limiter vraiment le risque au maximum
quand on commet sa soeur de la victime
automatiquement on va augmenter un petit
peu le risque donc c'est pour ça qu'avec
le club va organiser des entraînements
voltige dans un cadre sécurisé donc on
va mettre un bateau sur l'eau on a des
vues les sauvetages avec nous pour
l'essayer les des figures qu'on n'a pas
encore trop l'habitude de faire voilà
que ce travail un cadre sécurisé que si
jamais ça se passe pas comme on veut
qu'on ait le temps de tirer le parachute
de secours et de tomber dans l'eau
nous
sur la voltige on va chercher vraiment
le pilotage actifs en l'air la masse
d'air nous nous montrent elles nous
descend et puis suivant l'intensité de
la masse d'air on peut être ne serait-ce
que pacy parce qu'on se fait un peu
trimballé à droite à gauche comme dans
une rivière nous on va chercher un petit
peu ce pilotage actifs on va essayer de
sénou les maîtres de du parapheur